inconclusive
that's the result of the us
investigation into who fired this bullet
that killed palestinian-american
journalist shirin about
in the occupied west bank in may
the us state department says it was an
independent third-party examination and
called it an extremely detailed forensic
analysis it continued
concluded that gunfire from idf
positions likely responsible for the
death of shirin abu aklee and it added
it found no reason to believe this was
intentional but rather the result of
tragic circumstances
shireen's family issued a statement
saying they were incredulous considering
the numerous witness accounts and
investigations by numerous local and
international media outlets human rights
groups and the united nations that found
an israeli soldier fired the fatal shot
the investigation the entire
investigation is disappointing
considering the fact that we are not
aware of any of the
of the re of the process we were not
there was no transparency uh we were not
given enough information regarding the
investigation and we had found out about
it last minute
so to us we still continue to call for a
transparent and a just investigation the
palestinian foreign ministry also
rejected the findings
saying the examination was politicized
and had nothing to do with the bullet
israel's interim prime minister yer
lapid tweeted that israel expressed
grief about her death and that the
israeli army could not determine who was
responsible but there was no intention
to harm her
the defense minister benny gantz had
this to say
i would like once again to express my
sorrow over the death of journalist
sharina water
the security establishment looks at
investigating the truth as a supreme
value
regarding this case and despite the
laboratory examination of the bullet and
the relevant rifle it is not possible to
link this bullet to this victim nor to
the rifle therefore unfortunately it is
not possible to determine who opened
fire
the americans have been putting pressure
on the palestinians for weeks now to
hand over the bullet keen to put an end
to this case ahead of the first official
visit of u.s president joe biden at the
end of next week now they can say that
they carried out an independent
investigation and despite it being
inconclusive this case is now over
stephanie decker al-jazeera west
jerusalem